hey guys Pete here are you ready for
another installment of the twin peak
season one rewatch today I'm gonna do my
twin peak season 1 episode 4 recap and
review it's the fifth episode in the
first season and although the whole
first season is pretty strong it's
probably my least favorite episode to be
honest there's just not a lot that
happens that pushes the story forward
before we get into the episode itself
we'll look at the log lady intro this
was filmed after the season went into
syndication on the Bravo network so the
intros are interesting because they are
written after the fact for episode 4 the
log lady says even the ones who laugh
are sometimes caught without an answer
these creatures who introduce themselves
but we swear we have met them somewhere
before yes look in the mirror what do
you see is it a dream or a nightmare
are we being introduced against our will
are they mirrors I can see the smoke I
can smell the fire the battle is drawing
nigh so episode 4 was known as the
one-armed man it's a second episode in
the road that has neither a credit for
mark frost or David Lynch except for
being series creators it was written by
Robert angles and directed by Tim hunter
and it originally aired on May 3rd 1991
our man starts out at the Palmer
household Sarah Palmer is working with a
sketch artist giving a description of a
man that she saw in her vision prompted
by Leland she also tells them about her
vision that she had at the end of the
pilot where she saw a gloved hand
digging Laura's half heart necklace out
from under the rock where James and
Donna had put it Donna happens to be in
attendance while the sketch is being
made and she realizes that Sara's vision
was about someone taking that necklace
that she and James had put there and
could that be the killer we catch up
with agent Cooper who's questioning dr.
Jacoby he does some magic tricks with
golf balls and
doesn't really want to answer any
questions based on doctor-patient
confidentiality in an attempt to get a
reaction Cooper tells Jacobi that Laura
had sex with three men the night she
died and asked him if he was one of them
two that Jacobi says no and he says
Laura had secrets and around these
secrets she built a fortress that in my
six months seeing her I wasn't able to
penetrate and for which I consider
myself an abject failure the one bit of
information he gives to Cooper before he
leaves though Jacoby says that he
followed a man that Laura had spoken
about in their sessions and that man
drove a red Corvette so Cooper obviously
knows that's Leo Johnson coupe gets a
call from Gordon Cole we find out some
information about Gordon's analysis of
the body find out that the bite marks on
lower shoulder were from a bird and
Gordon also says that Albert hasn't
given up his bid to file criminal
charges against sheriff Harry Truman
Cooper doesn't want to have anything to
do with that he assures Harry that
nothing's gonna come of it and he tells
Gordon that he'll fight that all the way
up the chain to Washington if necessary
and he says to Harry the last thing you
need to worry about is some city slicker
I brought into your town relieving
himself upstream deputy Andy comes in
with the sketch of the man Sarah Palmer
saw in her vision and agent Cooper
confirms that this is the guy that he
saw in his dream and that it's the
killer named Bob deputy hawk has tracked
a mysterious one-armed man to an
out-of-the-way hotel same place where
he's staying Catherine Martell and Ben
Horne are using for their affair we see
the Josie Packard's outside she's trying
to take pictures of Ben and Catherine as
Cooper and the sheriff and deputy had
approached the room of the one-armed man
Andy accidentally drops his gun and it
goes off after that they bust enter the
room and the one-armed man is in a towel
shocked surprised and he doesn't come
off as someone who knows what's going on
we also see Ben go to take a shower and
when
getting his stuff together he drops a
poker chip from one-eyed jacks that
Katherine finds on the floor so they
question the one-armed man whose name
turns out to be Phillip Gerard they show
him the sketch of Bob and he claims he's
never seen that guy he asked him if he
has a friend named Bob and he says that
Bob Lydecker is his friend and that he's
probably the best darn bet in this area
the reason that Phillip Gerard was at
the hospital is because he was visiting
his friend who was assaulted in a local
bar fight we find out that he lost his
arm in a car crash and that he's also
selling shoes for a living he's a
traveling shoe salesman Cooper tries to
get him to describe the tattoo that was
on his missing arm in his dream he heard
that it said fire walk with me but
Gerard just starts crying here and he
said that he had a tattoo that said mom
on it I'm not sure if coop starts to
question his dream at this point but the
way this scene plays out you feel pretty
sympathetic for the one-armed man and it
doesn't seem like he could actually be
connected over at the school we see
Audrey talked to Donna at the bathroom
we see that Audrey has a bad girl streak
where she's blazingly smoking a
cigarette they exchange some information
find out that dr. Jacoby was treating
Laura that Laura was probably working as
a prostitute at one-eyed jacks that her
and Ron had both worked at the perfume
counter at her dad's department store
and she lets on that that's where she's
gonna start digging in and start her
investigation we see Norma go to her
husband's parole hearing we learned that
hank was arrested for killing a homeless
person and was there on a vehicular
manslaughter conviction Norma helps out
the situation by saying she's gonna give
Hank a job that they're husband and wife
she doesn't really seem sold on the
whole idea while she's there but she
does do what is most helpful to Hank in
this situation after that Cooper
and Truman go over to the Animal Clinic
that is run by Bob Lydecker Phillip
Gerard's friend it's a quirky scene a
quirky place and Cooper seems convinced
that the bird who attacked Laura Palmer
is a client of this office so they take
all the files with them back to the
sheriff's station
Bobbie and Shelley are together at
Shelley's place they're making out in
the kitchen
Bobby's pissed about James seeing Laura
behind his back but he's seeing Shelley
behind Leo's back right at the same time
he has a pretty funny shirt on it's like
a bowling shirt or something like that
and the name on it is dick which is kind
of funny
Shelley lets them know that leo is with
jock which Bobby obviously knows that
they're in business together because he
does business with them
Shelley ends up giving him the shirt
with the blood on it and she shows Bobby
the gun that she bought for protection
this leads us into a scene where we see
the guys because of Andy's dropping his
gun we see them down at the shooting
range we see that Cooper is the best
shot of the mall harry truman's not too
bad and he needs practice and lots of it
and we get a pretty cool Hawk moment
where he tells the story that he wrote
to his girlfriend and we learned that he
has a girlfriend named Diane Shapiro who
has a PhD but we never meet her in the
series we get one of those Shelley and
Norma moments where they talk about they
have two men apiece and no idea what to
do with any of the four of them we see
the identical cousin Maddy come in and
James kind of freaks when he sees her
and then Norma gets the phone call
confirming that Hank will be paroled and
she looks none too happy about it we
pick back up with Audrey who has put her
plan into motion she's gonna get herself
a job through her father over at horns
we see that she's manipulating a little
bit but also trying to get in his good
graces at the same time he gives her a
hug and then he gets a call which we
find out later is from
leo there's also an introduction there
where he's talking to his brother Jerry
and they're talking about bringing some
Icelandic people into the Great Northern
to talk to him about ghostwood because
the Lydecker files are not separated by
animal name but actually by the name of
the pet they have to do it like an
all-nighter kind of thing and we learn
when Gordon Cole calls back again that
the fragment found in lora stomach is a
poker chip and that the bird Bites came
from a parrot or a Myna bird at that
same time handy discovers that Jacque
Renault
owns a Myna bird named Waldo and this
gets Cooper all jacked up to go and raid
Jack's apartment but we already know
that he's gone having gone back with Leo
across the border back into Canada now
the poker chip is from one-eyed Jack's
and even though Jacques is not there
when they arrive Bobby Briggs had
already broken into the place so he was
there when they arrived and he's able to
leave the bloody shirt that he got off
of Shelley there which is got Leo's name
sewn into the collar and this makes them
look like pretty good suspects in
Laura's murder after that we see that
Benjamin Horne is doing his business
meeting by the river with Leo Johnson
he's gonna pay him money to burn down
the Packard mill in three days we find
out when he's talking to Katherine that
they want it to be set up so that it
looks like Josie burned it down for
insurance fraud because the place was
bankrupt
we also basically find out that Benjamin
Horne is involved in the local drug
trafficking and that Leo has taken care
of
the Renault brothers he said he made
sure that Jacque would stay in Canada
and poor little Bernard ended up dead
after he got out on his possession
charge and we see the body wrapped up
there so Leo did it himself after that
we see Donna and James go out to that
spot in the woods where they put the
necklace they can
ferm that is gone just like Sarah Palmer
saw in her vision James thinks they
maybe should go to the police which is
not a bad idea but it wouldn't be this
soap opera deal that these two have
going on if Donna didn't say something
ridiculous and in this case she says the
police didn't love Laura no one loved
her but us or nobody loved her but us so
yeah so we figure out the Donna and
James believe that they have a better
chance of figuring out what's going on
here rather than the police do things
end off over at the Packard place Pete's
asking Josie to be his partner there is
a fishing competition coming up with
mixed doubles we see that Pete is
obviously enamored with Josie here just
as Harry is and it's kind of cute I
guess the way that he sort of follows
after her obviously she plays right into
it and you know obviously Josie is an
attractive woman and very mysterious
still in this part of the thing so it's
kind of a nice little aside that they
have going on there we see Josie open
the letter after Pete leaves and it has
a drawing of a domino and then she gets
a phone call from Hank who is holding
the Domino that is depicted in the
drawing letting her know that he's
getting out of prison the way it goes
down he says catch you later so you kind
of get this idea that there's a
connection between these two characters
and if I'm not mistaken this is when we
find out that there is more to Josie's
character than just being this sweet
innocent person that she's kind of plays
up whenever we see her in her
interactions and that's pretty much it
here I mean I said it's my least
favorite episode of the first season but
that's really not saying much part of it
is you know when you re watch it a lot
of the drama that's made here is about
who the killer might be so it's not like
whenever you've seen and you already
know who the kill
is that that stuff's all that imperative
anymore so it's not like it was
completely misguided or written badly or
anything like that it fits into the
original season the way that it should
and it builds up things but it's just a
little bit lackluster in the way that
things go down compared to the other
episodes I mentioned that Tim Hunter was
the director he made a movie that was
out around the same time I guess it was
called river's edge and and had Keanu
Reeves and Dennis Hopper in it it was
actually a good movie I remember it I
haven't seen it for a very long time but
I enjoyed it when I was a kid so that's
interesting Hunter goes on and directs a
couple more episodes later on in season
two as far as trivia for the episode
goes it's kind of funny that and I don't
know that I ever really thought about
that deeply until I watched it this time
but when Ben's getting ready to go into
the shower at the motel he says he's
going to give little Elvis a bath and he
literally has a small little Elvis
statue now of course
Elvis referred to his own penis as
little Elvis so it's a reference to that
and I guess from what I've read this is
how they got it past the censors instead
of saying he was going into the shower
to wash his penis
he held up a little Elvis doll so that
it wouldn't seem like a reference to
what it actually is so that's kind of
funny this episode was actually viewed
by more people than watched the one
before it
this was whenever things were really
picking up for the series and I thought
it was interesting in the first time it
came out on May 3rd 1990 it was viewed
by eleven point nine percent of US
households that represents 19 percent of
everybody that was watching TV that
night so you have to think about that in
context I mean that was one in five
people who were watching TV in the u.s.
in 1990 watched this episode when it
first aired so that's pretty big you
know what I mean like if you weren't
around at that time to remember how much
of a hype there was a
the series that should give you a little
bit of an idea I think some of the
biggest things we find in this episode
is that Maddy is nothing like Laura in
fact she is sort of like a idealistic
version of what Laura might have been if
what we find out later in fire walk with
me and in other parts of this season and
the second season had been going on with
her so it's sort of like you know they
kind of made fun of the trope in the
last episode and then here I think that
it just shows that she's not really
there for any deep insight into Laura
herself but as a contrast to what Laura
might have been also Bob's the sketch of
Bob and we find it finding out that
Sarah Palmer's visions are somewhat
accurate is pretty big stuff I guess and
you know the stuff with Phillip Gerard
is obviously a little bit of
misdirection and we'll see how that all
plays out later on in season 1 that's it
for today guys I will probably have
another one of these out next week as
mentioned in previous videos this is
brought to you by my patreon patrons
they support this series by donating to
me over there I would love it if you
would join me too so follow the link at
the top of the screen or at the end of
the video and read more about it there
I'm thinking about going through the
second season as well which has
obviously a lot more episodes and will
take a lot more time so I'm hoping that
I'll be able to get some more people
involved over there and we can keep that
going because that will take quite a bit
of time to get through all of it please
like the video if you enjoyed it make
sure you subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already I have got some
different stuff coming out soon I'm
still working out exactly what I'm gonna
do in the downtime between mr. robot and
Westworld so if you have any ideas
that's another thing you can do is come
over on patreon and let me know what you
would like to see I'm gonna be doing
some voting over there in the near
future so the people who are
contributing and get to have a say in
what the channel will have going forward
that's it for today I will
talk to you soon